chis qu'onne sur le char par que ça ça
c'est
le RO Charles 3 atteint d'un concert les
informations sont sorties moi je
commence ça y est je commence à
m'intéresser à cette histoire je
commence à le kiffer comm à kiffer
vraiment le Charles 3 je commence à
vraiment le kiffer on va avoir toutes
les infos on va accueillir aussi Michel
bobotte médecin généraliste qui nous
donnera des conseils pour rester en
bonne santé Michel bobotte qui est en
momocass regard Charles JT ou 9 mois
seulement après son accession au trône
Charles I est atteint d'une forme de
cancer dans les rues de Londres beaucoup
de Britanniques sont sous le
choc je me sens un peu mal pour lui il a
attendu toutes ses années pour être roi
dans son communiqué Buckingham Palace a
annoncé que Charles I avait débuté un
traitement certains de ces sujets
l'inviteent à se battre se félicite que
la nouvelle soit rendue publique
d'autres lui conseillent de se mettre en
retrait merci Bertrand dekers qui est
avec nous qui est pas bien il y avait
votre frère Joël dekers
Le l'auteur était là c'est pour ça vous
avez mis un cœur comme ça oui oui c'est
pour ah ouais pas mal le docteur Bobot
aussi docteur Bobot je l'adore il est
incroyable franchement il est incroyable
et oui je l'adore je cherchéis un
médecin généraliste d'ailleurs quand
vous voulez c'est pour moi et mon père
mon père aussi tiens mon père aussi
c'est mon père c'est mon père qui me
soigne et voilà comme ça au moins vous
serez deux d'accord que mon père ne veut
plus me soigner dit que je suis trop
chiant donc voilà si vous voulez bien si
vous voulez bien c'est vrai mon père
peut plus me blérer euh voilà donc euh
Bertrand alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
don les informations du jour vraiment
par rapport à ce qui a été dit hier
c'est que le prince har est enfin arrivé
sur Londres il était 14h française il
était arrivé à l'aéroport 10 so vas Mo
déjà
qui dans le nord de Londres et
directement il a rejoint Clarence House
qui est la propriété Charles I et
Camilla étaient dans l'après-midi ils se
sont vu pendant 2h environ ils se sont
par
2 hor de de oui 2 hor assez longuement
et ensuite un hélicoptère enfin le une
demler a quitté la propriété donc du du
du roi pour se rendre à Buckingham
Palace et de là un hélicoptère à décollé
le roi est actuellement à sundingham
dans le Norfolk c'est un château qui
adorait Elisabeth 2 dans le Norfolk dans
le nord de l'Angleterre et et il se
repose nous ditons pour voilà pour
quelques jours mais on sait très bien
que d'après le communiqué il il va y
avoir des soins qui vont être répétés
donc le premier soin a eu lieu hier ce
qui veut donc dire que la presse pour
l'instant tableait s sur de la
radiothérapie on nous dit que
probablement hier il aurait une première
séance de radiothérapie qu'il va se
reposer pendant TR 3 qu jours qu'il va
donc revenir ce qui serait totalement
possible Cyril parce que c'est une
propriété qui est très proche de Londres
soningam c'est pas du tout la propriété
la plus il pas été en par exemple un
cancer c'est sur on va demander au
médecin parce que merci Monsieur merci
Docteur Bobot d'être là c'est il a quoi
alors le roi Charles 3 sais rien j'en
sais rien merci Docteur
[Applaudissements]
allez merci
Docteur merci merci Docteur
merci allez on va bouffer allez on va
bouffer je l'adore mais il y a-t-il un
lien entre le cancer je connais pas la
nature du cancer qu'il a la seule chose
qu'on sait c'est qu'a priori il faisait
examen pour pour un problème de prostate
il a à son âge doit avoir une
hypertrophie bénine de la prostate et
pendant l'examen ils ont découvert autre
chose mais c'est tout ce qu'on sait
d'accord donc voilà a priori il a un
cancer et a priori à un stade
suffisamment avancé pour qu'on envisage
un traitement d'accord et que ce soit
pas un traitement premier en chirurgie
c'est tout ce qu'on sait donc est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il a été détecté un peu
donc il a été détecté assez tard ça a
été détecté par inadvertence c'estàd
qu'on cherchait pas et on a trouvé ça ah
d'accord voilà mais ça voilà ça c'est
intéressant d'accord voilà donc mais
c'est souvent comme ça parce que le
cancer finalement quand ça commence à
parler c'est un peu tard ah ouais c'est
pour ça que la prévention est un élément
extrêmement important il faut prévenir
les cancers que ce soit les cancers chez
la femme avec le sein et la mammographie
ou le cancer du col de l'utérus avec
l'HPV donc je vous engage tous à vous
vacciner enfin tous les gens qui n'ont
pas eu de relation sexuelle a priori à
se vacciner contre l'HPV voilà c'est ça
et et et et surtoutam elle est ah voilà
désolé et et surtout arrê et surtout
arrê arrêtez de fumer vous voyez le
graphique est extrêmement clair chez la
femme et chez l'homme le premier cancer
des deux c'est effectivement le cancer
du poumon donc c'est le tabac donc on
peut on peut éviter en prévenant les
cancers donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut le
FO c'est l'alcool ou pas le foi en en en
l'occurrence oui pas queou vraiment il y
a quoi d'autre l'alimentation sur quoi
l'obésité ah ouais ouais et ouais donc
donc on peut arriver à réduire le nombre
de cancers en ayant une alimentation
saine une hygiène de vie correcte alors
c'est quoi les cancers les cancers les
plus dangereux parce que on dit que
souvent le cancer du pancréas c'est
c'est par que c'est c'est c'est
compliqué c'est ça c'est compliqué ça va
assez vite ou ça va assez vite en
l'occurrence le cancer de la prostate
chez la personne de 75 ans est un cancer
d'évolution assez lente d'accord par qu'
en fait en fait ce qu'il faut savoir et
ce que je dis pour les téléspectateurs
que ce que dit le docteur c'est que plus
vous êtes âgé moins la maladie va
rapidement évol exement elle va évoluer
plus plus lentement quand vous êtes âé
donc en fait c'estm
mie d' quand on a une maladie comm ça on
a un on a une fréquence extrêmement les
de tiers des cancers apparaissent entre
50 et 65 ans voilà c'est c'est vraiment
le le le moment où entre 50 et 70 ans
c'est là où il faut faire de la
prévention parce que c'est là où les
cancers apparaissent quand ils
apparaissent très jeunes les cancers
évoluent rapidement c'est souvent les
leucémies par exemple et ça évolue
rapidement et c'est tou enfin c'est
souvent de mauvais pronostic mais quand
on est
âgé le corps étant âgé les cellules us
le son aussi c'est ça et donc elle
prolifère moins vite exactement c'est ça
ou bah les gars docteur Hanouna quand je
suis avec un collègue là on s je vois à
qui parler qu'est-ce que vous vouliez
dire pardon moi je voulais dire que si
on remonte un peu dans l'histoire le
grand-père du roi George 6 est mort d'un
cancer du poumon le sa et on pense
qu'Élisabeth II même si le rapport
médical ne sera jamais rendu public
officiellement elle est morte de
vieillesse il y a quand même des bruits
très bien informé près de la cour qui
nous dit qu'en réalité elle souffrait
d'un cancer des os donc ce qui voudrait
quand même donc dire que le grand-père
la merre voilà je ne sais pas le
grandpère le grand-père pouvait avoir un
cancer du poumon parce qu'il
fumait voilà et et et et la grand-mère
pouvait avoir un cancer des eau qui
aurait été une localisation secondaire
d'un cancer du il y a aucune hérédité
dans les cancers il y a une hérédité
dans les cancers bien sûr SR bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr il y a une héit dans
les cancers on a par exemple dans les
familles on sait quand on a des des des
des gens qui ont eu dans dans leur
famille père ou mère des cancers du
colon on va avoir tendance à les sur
beaucoup plus rapidement et pas attendre
5 pour faire les premières coloscopies
sûr qu' une hdité d'accord alors juste
pour le roi est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
continuer à assurer ses fonctions mais
ça justement voilà quel traitement
va-t-il être apporté on sait très bien
que les personnes ne réagissent pas de
la même façon si c'est de la
radiothérapie si c'est de la
chimiothérapie vous ê remplacé par qui
sinon temporairement alors il y a une
loi voilà qui nous dit que ce sont les
conseillers de la Couronne qui seuls
sont habilités à pouvoir représenter le
roi le premier de ses conseillers c'est
Camila tout d'abord qui est son épouse
donc elle le les entrins et puis
évidemment c'est le prince William qui
reprend du service desès mercredi
jusqueà maintenant il ne fait absolument
plus rien depuis près d'un mois parce
que souvenez-vous il est auprès de Kate
midolton
qui et qui elle fera également et en
effet dans la campagne ad cottage et a
quand même
étééré
alors elle est vraiment ferala ououi
puisque 14
jours docteur oui docteur c'est quoi
elle est souffrante docteur d'accord ok
c'est ça que ça veut dire elle est
comment elle est comment Ellez c'est un
terme de médecineelle feral elle est
feral pour un problème voilà on pense
bien de l'ordre gynécologique voilà donc
on rappelle quand même 14 jours
d'hospitalisation et quand même une
suspension de toute activité jusqu'au
mois d'avril Cyril donc donc c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué d'accord donc
donc là donc on va suivre elle est elle
est elle est toujours toujours toujours
feral non vraiment d'accord d'accord
toujours faireal merci euh merci en tout
cas merci beaucoup euh d'avoir été là
euh docteur est-ce qu'on a quelque chose
à ajouter voorsi deux choses la première
c'est d'abord ce ce que ce que ça
m'amène à penser de la mort d'un père
d'accord donc en fait en dehors du fait
que ce soit un roi c'est un père qui est
malade avec des enfants qui sont
extrêmement inquiets et probablement un
rapprochement familial dans un contexte
dans lequel quand on perd quelqu'un de
très très proche comme ça on va se
rapprocher et puis on va se dire des
choses qui sont importantes et je trouve
que ça c'est triste et qu'il soit le roi
ou pas en tout cas ça reste un homme
donc c'est c'est toujours bien de de de
d'entendre ça et puis la deuxième chose
c'est un tout petit mot sur le système
de santé anglais et ça c'est important
dans le contexte parce que là les
Français sont intéress voilà le le
système de santé anglais c'est un
système par capitation c'est-à-dire que
finalement vous avez c'est ce qu'on
souhaite monsieur le Président Macron
c'est vous avez une somme qui est
allouée par patient le patient choisit
pas son médecin le médecin choisit pas
son patient et les délis d'attente
pardon en Angleterre sont extrêmement
longs c'estd que dans un contexte comme
celui-là entre le moment où vous
suspectez un cancer vous êtes traité il
faut 4 à 6 mois alors qu'en France il
faut quelques semaines et et là ce que
ça montre ici c'est quand même que dans
un pays comme l'Angleterre quand on a du
pouvoir et de l'argent on va très vite
et c'est vraiment de se dire est-ce
qu'on a envie de ça en France bien sûah
c'est intéressant merci Doct toujours un
bonheur de vous avoir et vous aussi et
on t'aime d'accord soit pas en Racer non
on est là et j'espère que tu seras
jamais faire c voà merci euh